hello there reject nation of Greg Alba
time John Humphrey BTS time who was BTS
you might ask well it doesn't mean
behind the scenes unless you're talking
about where your real love is that's in
the seven members of mind hand can you
name the seven members of bangtan yes
it's all in this video that's the top
rewards here video requests Natalie
Doran Natalie Doran wonderful human
being very kind very beautiful very
sharp very Irish very Catholic very
religious is waiting till marriage
before she does anything with any guy
unless she is hungry looking for a lot
of BTS inside of her all seven members
of bang oh yeah at our patreon page we
do weekly Q&A is TV show reaction stream
along some of reaction how it's included
but wanted to mention Humpty Dumpty
Dumpty lump does music video reactions
over our patreon page and sometimes
let's kite pop music usually once a week
or something
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
one of the best rappers rap monster
[Music]
the first member who flemingsburg
Oh interesting well label big hit Hill
boy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in real estate some little studio
produce on his own
[Music]
friends my favorite spot
tickets for the lives this is gonna be
here thank you and the beam on make new
fans in here Wow
thank you for having also we will show
you everything today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so it was so hard in Vegas it was like
30 35 Celsius but you know I've heard
that you know guys were waiting for the
majestic Harper like like from the
morning I mean like from done like 5:00
a.m. I cannot imagine that are you
trying so much like for everything for
the medium age you know like Hoffman's
yeah like iTunes he was you know you
teach art thank you he's got hella
action figures Jim
[Music]
Wow
he is handsome get him in the band I bet
he can sing too oh yeah I seen that
video cards or
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wow capitalize on your hands I bet if we
spoke Korean from Peru testing it horn
honking door opens hi Bo's not a
territory circuit and a chain an
external antenna it seemed a little
shimmy and Cerberus occupancy toll on
the Cannonball a recorded vote
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
oh hell yeah love with him
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know what he's saying but still
wildly and I'm
[Music]
they're all deep but they're just deep
in different ways
[Music]
[Music]
Wow damn
[Music]
[Music]
you fit in in California
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I want that song give that song
[Music]
that's okay
he's the sexiest it's gonna be hard to
talk with me
every time they introduce someone think
it's
[Music]
oh really
[Music]
[Music]
is the cute one
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so P me
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
see that kind of dancing - yeah I think
you would be great in a kpop idol group
dance temporary
[Music]
our duties is have sex with each other
oh yeah carries he's by the sloppiest
one
[Music]
oh yeah he's a seductive he's the one
who knows
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
actually whips himself daily yes the
American Way
and clearly that's the way to do and if
you take its few breaks as possible it's
even more impressive
Wow is really hard on himself yes high
standard on game time it's right
somewhere
[Music]
[Music]
it's crazy like I don't think I'm right
here don't think my voice is good enough
to money most of the must be under God
yeah yeah cannot imagine but I guess
those know they get to where they are
yeah you gotta have that set of
standards you're never there v the
hardest member to tag in these videos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tender one
[Music]
I gather kids first
[Music]
[Music]
love to me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I belong somewhere
the Cold War is a something to worry
about had an important use of coal a
Virginia
you know what are you do
[Music]
[Music]
so uh-oh sounds like you're young what
relate it's thoughtful
Fitz that's what I was thinking yeah
[Music]
those are my hobbies two men I get some
more sacks of these tracks
Oh
[Music]
do it for the gram
he's a Virgo Hey
doesn't matter you and I are the you're
my favorite
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the reaction of too much though
[Music]
and yet services fear of God I think God
should fear you oh yeah
God checks under his bed for junk
cooking he's good at everything
[Music]
[Music]
15 years old
[Music]
what damn dog that is nuts
[Music]
they like
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
like we can heart
[Music]
Oh Chester
[Music]
hey those are definitely the best
brothers that I had two older brothers
wickets it's crazy
[Music]
okay I think influencer see ah dude
influence from the last
[Music]
[Music]
you
Oh
[Music]
they're like freaked out about 2015 I
know now what's the time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I love all the videos and then with all
their crazy accolades people say that
but a purple guy kind of awkward can't
help but notice how purple they are yeah
like what are you can't help but think
it it might sound racist
are you just a bruise or dream I've met
green people too I'm polite I don't
bring it up I don't say anything cuz
that would be rude and I would just come
across races but when you meet someone
who is pure green like I'm just trying
to make sure I seem normal around you
and not aware that you're green tell me
about your life do you need help yeah
well I'll feel that way with Mexican
people there is but not the people of
South Korea I'm just joking they're
called jokes
oh man jokes humor why it's not all of
these things are serious there's a test
at the only I didn't have so many
Mexican friends than I than that then
I'd feel comfortable to make that then I
would feel embolden many races for real
oh this is wonderfully put together this
is wonderfully put together it's really
cool to get a breakdown of all seven of
them and what they specifically bring to
the table and what they're primarily
viewed as in terms of the personal
relationships to I think is really cool
it's easy to kind of grass on
information because of how communicative
they are with their audience expressing
they are honest they are how they'll be
vulnerable even when they're not doing
performances I think that's really cool
I mean that's but how much of it is real
how much of it is real there's always a
camera everything's monetized
everything's corporate what's going on
BTS yeah but for the
I will let all those cynical suspicions
thrown out the window and I'm just gonna
accept this and believe it all to be
sincere okay well I'm sure the comments
will be rife with people providing you
tons of evidence to support that's what
we do but yeah that's been the fun part
about this journey is just their
undeniable the more you learn about the
seven members of bangtan the more you
just are endeared to everything that
they do and you gotta give them respect
cuz you pointed that out during the
videos like these dudes are on top of
the world right now and yet at least
some of them by this video's admission
or arm still beating themselves up for
not being good enough and that is
inspiring when you also see the
juxtaposition of how down to earth they
seem to be you know how kind of
thoughtful they all seem to be yeah yeah
that's very true it's easy to look at
these guys and you know and I imagine
hard-working folk I always imagine even
for these performers who are as lively
as they are when they're on stage I
still get on the impression that you
know when they're backstage or when
they're not performing that they're
probably really serious people and then
you see them and like my favorite stuff
and I feel like probably for most people
with videos like this is looking at some
footage it doesn't feel like a
documentary or interview but you know
like they're just recording each other
on their phones or something like
they're just having a fun time [ __ ]
with each other like those are probably
the biggest highlights yeah because you
see just how much fun they do have and
how funny they all are actually all of
them have like a really big sense of
humor they're willing to make fun of
each other they're willing to poke fun
at themselves that's cool this video
does explore how yeah of course they
have some conflicts within the groups
and then there's people who it's like a
leader RM who's also those destructured
it's pretty cool by how like which
member comes next yeah you know they're
well wrap around how this journey really
began well and they jump to different
aspects because it's not just like let's
do all the rappers first ya know I
thought it was really well spread around
personality-wise yeah and we're like RM
tell they're talking about with him
being a leader and having to help solve
conflicts this is really cool to see
they are just people there they're not
just a product
you know they are are human beings it's
insane how young they are yeah you know
I show up to that one dudes high school
graduation I will say like there's seven
of them and I feel all seven deadly sins
when I see these guys and for sure lust
I'm lusting after them all right pride I
am so proud of their accomplishments
yeah you're half asian so yeah you have
a right to be proud of that very true
Humphry gluttony I feel fat when I see
how sexy their bodies are envy that's a
given
well rage that you're not comin rageful
then right I'm not then but then when
they're rapping against they're haters
I'm like yeah I feel that rage and
there's two more sins they make you feel
lazy for I don't know kind of that old
same stuff which is just the fact that
I'm talking about this and not doing
anything about it shows a lazy eye and
then greed do you know they make you
feel greedy which I was get another DTS
it's the main thing I look at above all
else beyond their personalities their
discipline their hard work as I go man
look at all that money look at all that
money that's the main thing I would
strive for right there the other thing
to you that's really cool sorry I
started a bit I had to finish it back in
them serious ma ya know the other thing
too is how much of artists they they
truly are you know they write their own
stuff
they'll collab with other people and
really provide their own creativity on
their artists and every one of these
arenas like with the choreography of the
dance moves seeing them get involved in
their own little studio is like BOTS
were there for nill pretty you can't get
like a shit-ton it's not like those
movies where you got like that producer
with the glasses in the background there
the one dude who's like like just not
getting it just not getting the know
there is nothing that you can do here in
this room that can turn that around well
my mother locks in there hold on your
mother was wrong today your performance
has shaken my belief in the Jewish
people we owe that grand piano let's
rearrange the whole room you see just
people who as they keep going when I was
talking about how the eye
they wanted to be like successful and
have money make a career out of it but
they didn't want Fame that even amongst
the fame and amongst all the success
they have they're still trying to reach
new heights of creative capability and
also yeah you do see their level of
standards like when you see gym and
backstage and he's freaking out about
how he his mic fell off his voice
cracked ones yeah everyone's gonna be
around him and you know tell them what I
would even say to someone is you know
it's just one performance or sure no one
even really noticed yeah a value but
it's that standard that you set for
yourself the lid that you have where
it's like you you don't want to go below
it and weather is not racing they know
and I know it you have a standard of
delivery as a worker as a performer
that's just really great to see I love
this because it did feel very insightful
into the humanity what really hit me
here how [ __ ] young they're so young
and it's so inspiring to see the level
of sacrifice they've made at such young
ages and really willing to go against
the grain this really opened up my eyes
to the discussion that had between pop
music and rap music and how they had to
deal with image transition who out here
in the States
is like Britney Spears and Eminem you
know who can do that
Justin Timberlake and jay-z who's
operating but I mean like that yeah and
we're seeing too I mean like it's
interesting because there has been a
rise at least in the Western hip-hop
scene of late of people who do want to
switch back and forth a lot between
singing and rapping but even that is not
the full dual spectrum where it's like
you're on the pop level usually and then
you're right on like the hardcore
hip-hop level and that was something
that was neat to me to see also
everybody's come up both for the fact
that you had at least a good couple of
the guys being like I never imagined
myself being you know the main singer I
just came in to do dance I think was V
or somebody talking about like I want to
be able to sing my own song that I wrote
it's easy to look I think in a group
like this and see all the Polish and
think oh you know committee makes the
music but to see them dig deep into the
production and also learning the instrum
and incorporating those into the shows I
thought was cool and then he had to go
back into the specific come ups I think
it's funny that they've become such a
huge worldwide phenomenon and I feel
like they've broken out even beyond
phenomena and they've broken out you
know beyond kpop even I think and my
limited perspective because yeah you
have that identity crisis at the
formation of the group where it's like
the hip-hop scene doesn't accept the
hip-hop members anymore and the pop
scene doesn't accept them either and I
feel like being in that weird no-man's
land has created this unique thing that
I feel like that is the key magic is
when you take something that none of the
groups really accept you can create
magic there and yeah these guys who are
on the rap side of it are clearly
dedicated and when they go off both
doing you know just like a solo song
within BTS or a solo song on their own
project like these guys are clearly
capable all of them and he had to see
the way that they influence each other
too was pretty inspiring as well because
it made me curious about the structure
too because they were talking about the
dance line so I'm like okay a few of
these guys are probably more in the
front of the dance aspect and then a
couple of the guys are more toward the
back end doing more of the rapping or
vocal aspects and it made this so much
more fascinating to see all of their
different contributions to the group and
how they all came from what seems like a
lot of different places and backgrounds
and motivations and found their way to
this and it enhances that magic of like
you never know where one pursuit is
gonna take you whether that's dance or
singing or rapping or what you know yeah
that's really cool
mm-hmm that's great yeah I would love to
see the rappers collaborate with em yes
let's get a beat yes I think okay next
Eminem record what he should do is it
should be a seven-track EP no eight
tracks nine tracks okay nine track EP
first it's an album now first in the
last track it's Eminem and the whole
group and then all the seven songs in
between it's mmm and one member of BTS
each mmm that's not a bad to Eminem yeah
BTS with the backwards e at the end BTS
E
yeah or B yes t BS t-- oh love yourself
best and it'll be the most aggressively
inspiring empowering kpop at the sock
pop and rock pop drop hop
I've got Jimin engine and jump easiest
bear best with mmm and like Eliot Ness
yeah that'd be cool
I want Eminem beats yes well Gus thanks
for this guy's if you are you know fans
of BTS save something in the comments I
suppose whatever you want to name your
favorite BTS thing you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
Bell check us out on patreon where we
got those goodies and John does music
video reactions weekly and thanks again
Natalie Doran who I found out has
o-negative blood oh man
but the words o-negative don't come to
mind when we talk about you in our lives
it's all possible a your shout outs
wooden half a little bit at the top
Thank You Natalie
you too bomb you know how much we love
you but especially Joe oh yeah Curtis
and especially now I call it a crotons
oh don't take oh I it's not a BTS video
until we say Crow tits